今天是颱風假
哎呀可是我要告訴你
台股颱風假
你家少數120萬
真的嗎
欸 同學
昨天網路上有人說我被打臉了
我被打臉嗎
臉有腫嗎
對啦今天是放假了啦
可是問題是
今天外面怎麼樣
無風
無雨
好無聊
同學沒有
所以我來上班了
我本來就是工作狂
只是我現在六日
比較多時間在運動
不然其實以前
你都看到我六日都在錄影
應該六日跟日
都有影片或文章
同志朋友
我問你一件事情
我昨天還說
這是AI跟傳統模式的一個差別
當然我也不要去批評
政府或地方政府
只是讓我廢話幾句
如果以後還有什麼叫
準備颱風架
防防颱風架
以後拜託不要看氣象報告了
就直接放假就好了
没有这样子搞的啦
同学你看我讲话很中立
以前有人说我偏蓝的偏白的
没有啊你不能这样放假
按规矩做事情
韩国美国日本香港
基本上没有台风假
以前香港还有
我讲的不是一般人
我讲的是股市
股市不会因为台风假放假
重点是无风无雨
晚上才有
要是明天放假
没有关系
讲这边讲
不要讲太多
好不好
昨天我們看一下
最近這幾天股市都很強啊
為什麼都很強
大家跟他say hello
這錄的不是直播
是直播啦
你不要亂啦
Mark
對啊
剛剛跟你講而已
是直播直播
好不好
完全沒有必要放假
台子期檔
這樣子
台子期檔到600多點嘛
是不是
633嘛
我們不要變成批評人家了
不要變批評人家
不要這樣子
我不是要
我原政策是這樣子
好不好
政家主要取消台風價
是真的啊
因為其實
不是啊
因為你知道嗎
來
那個成交量不見就不見了
你知道嗎
不見就不見了
很多人還是要靠交易量賺錢啊
是不是
好不好
然後 AI考量不到政治因素
你這個邏輯是錯誤的
它是 AI考量不到政治因素
我昨天問的 AI
他沒有
我昨天問的 AI 是 AI 走勢圖
AI 有時候有定義
大概放20%到30%的放假之余
不是嗎
我昨天有跟你講嘛
是不是
OK吧
這次好
算你剪頭髮了
謝謝你
我今天早上去剪頭髮
強烈建議則出來選市長
阿彌陀佛
我不參與政治
政治很恐怖
OK
來
台股要看大北犯家
我也想跟簡卷一樣的帥頭髮
對嘛
你們不要選到韓星嘛
我這種頭髮多好看
對不對
台灣style
頭髮用高一點
頭
來來
第一次看直播哭了
沒開盤
對啊
還有台風準備一架
今天沒有1
沒有關係
我們有另外一個1
來
Hello
大家好
你是誰
我是小韓
你是小韓喔
不好意思他給Key了一個麥克風
大家喔
哈囉大家好
聲音好像斷線沒聲音真的假的啊
有 有聲音
有聲音喔你不要來亂喔
完平喔嚇死我
今天穿著很清爽
所以我今天想要穿著一個比較
有那個有身材的衣服
好啦扯遠的來來來
我給你結論啦
禮拜一台灣股市會展啦
那為什麼說你少賺那個130萬
這是誇大啦來來看一下
來看一下
看這個看這個
那個我們來算一下
聲音小聲聲音
來颱風叫小漲了3%
台股股民少漲多少錢我上給你看
上市貴總市值163億
這個是多算的大概100億
不管我就粗略算了100兆說100兆
100兆163兆管一億的GDP或者是狹隘的GDP
大概只要100兆以上上市加上貴
假設攢3%嘛
就一度攢3%啊
一度攢3%啊
好不好
一度啦
就是摩台值啊
副台值啊
除1448萬的人的開戶數目
等於每個人這樣
每個人少賺33.8萬
當然也有人算6萬啦
因為
怎麼樣
因為一半的是被外資賺走
我不管啦
不管是33萬還是6萬
你
你就是少賺那麼多錢
你就是少賺好幾萬
那每個人少賺33.8千元
再乘以四比就130万
今天台股散展你少赚钱
不是啊
我觉得为什么不能两千其美
我不懂
我真的不懂
有些人就会怕人家骂
我也不懂
为什么不能晚上犯家
你真的要犯年是晚上犯家
是不是
为什么不能下我爸家
我也不知道
重点是无风无欲
好无聊
哎呀
每个人
尊重每个人想法
我知道很多人想犯家
可是像我做的
我想工作款怎么办
股市没开很无聊
你們應該也想要
也想要吧對不對
也想要開盤吧對不對
你們這些古迷
對不對
這邊沒有聲音
怎麼一直做沒有聲音啊
這邊有聲音嗎
有 我們這邊確定
你自己要卡開喔
好不好
沒有聲音要跟我講一下
我們這邊確定有喔
無風無離好無聊
整個最敬業的台風就要上班
對 我們摩爾的人都很敬業好不好
摩爾今天好多人
好不好
沒聲音耶 怎麼一直都沒聲音啊
我們這邊放在這裡
不要來亂喔 一直有人說沒聲音
你確定沒聲音嗎
你們再看一下
沒聲音要重新開 按重新開
重新連結再用一次
OK
聲音斷斷續續的
有啦 有聲音
好啦 會看到古民
有 很大聲
好好好
再打開 重新打開
把畫面重新打開 好不好
我們不要 我們往前走
對啊 我就說按制度走嘛
暗制住幹嘛要有制度
這就是我邏輯啊
然後準備假
那我要不要禮拜四也放假
我要不要來個那個颱風休息
颱風
那個收拾家園假
然後這往東西都
就沒有颱風
你起來亂
而且我告訴你喔
說你明天颱風很小喔
其實這次是我贏喔
我比AI搶
我也比傳統模式搶喔
我昨天有講喔
我給你看昨天的畫面喔
懶得播重播囉
我說有可能放政治假
AI是這麼誇張
這麼遠對不對
這AI模式沒錯吧
這AI模式有沒有
離台灣那麼遠對不對
然後這是那個
傳統模式基本上已經快要登入了
你們看到 離台灣的記你們到
是不是 AI在這邊
傳統模式在這邊
你看我們最新的
你看我最新的
我要再預測明天的
現在一直往北偏
最新的你看
這麼北
原本在這邊對不對
沒錯吧
現在這邊
往北很多
沒有錯吧
原本是在這邊
你看一下傳統模式
所以更不需要放假
不要说今天啦
连明天
明天当然该犯啦
因为明天有万一
可是连明天的风雨都比小人中小
我讲的是
连明天的风雨都比小人中小
少赚很多啦
我不要讲那么多台风
等一下我要讲股票啦
今天最重要的股票是什么
环球金
环球金美光
环球金礼拜要喷了啦
喷喷喷喷喷喷
那我只告诉你
你看现在这是最新的
刚才11点 2点
就是刚才我们现在2点半直播嘛
那个
那個
小楊幹嘛跟我說是
亂我的節奏
小楊把自己當聽中了
11點
11日
2點
有沒有看到
小楊看得很怒迷
看我節目看得很怒迷
來
早是在這邊
原本傳統模式在這邊
我哪邊錯
我不是跟你說介於AI跟人中間
所以你AI這次有贏
你用傳統模式
你看起來要放假
你如果是用那個
如果你說現在來看的話
今天真的不該放假
今天更不該放假
明天都一半一半
你懂不懂
這件事你看
這穿什麼模式
以前穿什麼模式
比較人工的
是在這邊
大概這邊嘛對不對
現在最新在這邊啦
AI在這邊啦
我是不是說一半一半
沒錯吧
AI在這邊有沒有
現在大概這邊有沒有
沒錯吧現在這邊吧
是不是你看一下
最新的有沒有
沒錯啊
沒有之前那麼近啊
這是事實啊
事實
擺在眼前事實
細長細長
好不好
好啦
跟大家講啦
所以好
全台員可以犯
就台員不能犯
不是啦
我覺得以後犯就犯
證交所就開吧
是不是
不要不是
我覺得我們
我自己說真的
我也不要得罪了
不是
我覺得不需要延長交易時間
大家痛苦
但該開的時候要開啊
好
OK
整整梅書
整整政治立場
可以這樣運放
真的
可是我在講的
變成調整政治
我覺得台灣
就是要有規矩啦
好不好
OK
台股這破Vetum了嗎
來
台股下禮拜
會不會
就是為了政治嘛
年底選舉嘛
好
就不要講
我講
再躲我三感情
所以我跟你講
這次感覺好像批評
批評台北市市長
有時候我也在批評別人
你就覺得我好像
一尾藍的
一尾白的
一尾綠的
沒有
我全台灣我最中立
有沒有看到
我很方力
好不好
OK
來
來來
我們不要這樣講
昨晚美股賴著大展
關通CPO是否要回展
我先跟你講邏輯
昨天CPO有些股票
美股CPO算不錯
可是我跟你講來來看一下
今天頭版新聞有沒有看到
大立官
手朵手磚CPO
有沒有看到
所以CPO訂單有沒有看到
有沒有看到 你看到
封裝官寫CPU有沒有看到
你看到大力官封裝官寫做一個官制而已
沒想到大力官也可以做CPU
所以我跟你講啊 台灣的很多CPU都是泡沫
台灣那些CPU
我是不是來接我的邏輯
我有時候真的很不想得罪人家
但我講話實在
CPU是趨勢
不代表CPU做CPU會賺錢
就像二三十年前一樣
奇美店只要搞個奇美面板
一樣
面板是趨勢
宏基要搞面板一樣
一堆公司要搞面板一樣
華映搞面板一樣
搞虧錢又虧錢
面板是趨勢
以前印象管
電視怎麼偷啊
這麼厚啊
面板是趨勢
代表面板會賺錢嗎
不是嘛
CPU是趨勢
代表CPU產生會賺錢嗎
不是嘛
你漲個1000塊是幹什麼
泡沫
你們看我基本上我不碰啊
上全玩要碰一點點而已
可是賺價差異
你那種漲法不對啦
漲到什麼幾百塊幾千塊
隨便你看到最後就是趨勢
這些會賺錢嗎
你看我還說有可能大廠商
躲到CPO勒
我這都預告過了
啊我跟你講
啊沒關係
你們要自己騙自己沒關係
啊我要是基本面好的
什麼叫基本面好的
最近一堆記憶體的新聞來看一下
今天晚上啦
SK海利是ADR超合認購7倍啦
基底太熱了啦
低論價還要漲18%啦
三星給你漲20%啦
有沒有看到
今天晚上這很重要喔
打開你的軟體
打不開沒關係
明天太無聊了
我離右利喔
基本上我花很多時間在重訓
這樣有沒有看到
現在比較少啦
因為作為發炎
我的肺結結
那個手術還沒有好
就是聽說好要半年
所以每次做完運動以後要一段時間休息
又開始咳嗽
代表人家可能在發炎中
所以慢慢來
完六日其實我都花很多時間在
在重訓啊 深蹲啊
然後跑步啊 自我對話
我花滿多時間自我對話
所以為什麼很多同業的攻擊啊
玩偶攻擊是活得好好的
因為我想來想去我也沒做什麼壞事啊
是啊
我一個1.71美在放到這樣
我少賺2億我也沒怎麼樣啊
當然會不會心疼
但我覺得誠信比較重要啊
所以我還是要講一件事情
來來來
這則是全台灣唯一喔
我會講一次喔
昨天給你們看過嘛對不對
全台灣是唯一喔
這個之前有什麼搞
有人亂搞一個自救會喔
要告我跟主力掛鉤
出貨給賞戶 出貨給委員
全台灣唯一法院證交所證明
決不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
他們告我
檢察官直接簽結
什麼叫簽結
連不起訴都沒有
什麼意思
有分起訴跟不起訴嗎
不起訴說你沒有什麼問題
起訴也不代表你有了罪
你知道嗎
先起訴比較嚴重 再不起訴
最不嚴重的就是前傑
就是你根本就沒什麼問題嘛欸 前傑是不能亂前傑的喔因為前傑那些要告我的人不能再告了你知道嗎不好意思證交水有還我清白
我講都事實啊
朝我所有紀錄啊
看我有沒有偷下股票啊
還真的沒有咧
不好意思咧
我又沒有一定要賺那麼多錢
我又沒差
我幹嘛要這樣偷偷賺那些錢
我很不屑
我很不屑 我真的不屑
我現在做事情是為了人生一個成就感
就像我所謂預測的行情
預測這個颱風價
以前我也會很生氣
沒有預測到 我現在也沒有
昨天我也跟你講清楚政治價
政治價很難預測啦
那沒有意義
你自己看今天台北市有風有雨嗎
一點點小風小雨
你不要跟我說很嚴重
當然每個人看我不同
我只是舊式認識
就沒有
規矩到了就該放
規矩沒得到了你怎麼放
我不要扯遠了
很多事情你就發現
全台灣唯一法院證明
證交所證明
去查
我那個新興的股票
我有沒有偷買偷賣
叫會員買然後我自己偷賣
笑死人了
罵我的時候70塊
現在漲到1000多塊
今天跌了20%
跌了300塊還有800塊
在這邊罵我啦
這邊檢舉我啦
這邊這邊這邊啦
不到100塊的時候
所以我告訴你喔
你以後很多人
斬平板是假的
我實實在在
全台灣唯一一個法院證明
證交所證明
我絕對不跟主力掛鉤的
我也要偷買股票
我覺得這個紀錄真棒
簽解啊
簽解的缺點就是不能在網路上找
有沒有 現在
昨天律師來跟我講說查不到
我當然知道查不到
但是書記官說
你真的想要知道可以問
這都記錄的啦
確骨 你自己問
114年至他至1233號
直接簽解
好啦 扯遠了
我們要跟他講
我們講這扯遠的扯遠
不要跟昨天一樣的東西
我們來看一下記憶體
第一題來看這第一題
來來
這SK海利是很重要有沒有看到
好
那SK海利是重要就算了 來
美觀呢
對怎麼樣
對美國投資2500億美元
厲不厲害
長期40%低潤在美生產
在美生產怎麼樣
需不需要矽晶圓
需要啊
半導體細菌源
很多人會覺得
這次半導體細菌源不是應該是
台積電 聯電 世界先進嗎
不是耶
是嗎
環球金獲到美觀十年大丹
美觀要在美國投資2500億美金
最重要是材料
最善有的材料是細菌源
我不論是記憶體的這些晶片
還是半導體
就是半導體相關晶片
台積的這些晶片
它上面的材料
就是矽晶圓
就是環球晶圓生產的
是不是啊
它提供五億美晶
有沒有看到
跟它合作
Mamma Mia
原來你看
所有技術現行有時候偷講話
難怪環球晶這麼厲害
你有沒有自己把我回答
我說我國際出地要賺一倍
我這接下來下一個一倍
最有一倍的是誰
我說你一千塊
國際真的不要買了啦
你要買一千塊的國際
你會買一千塊的環球金
某某某某這樣講類似的話
有
小黃有沒有講
有啦
看起來環球金禮拜一有機會展平
這種展法就只有兩千啦
就有盤感很厲害
就像精彩有沒有
所以你看我精彩在直接說
大戶如果沒有
大戶如果這個大戶
我沒有拉到展平丟臉
那我是開玩笑
我是覺得這大富很厲害
是不是
跟你講
不需要跟主力配合
大富也好
外資也好
我都知道他們在想什麼
我都知道
他們在做什麼事情
什麼亂設目標價
哪些外資比較認真
哪些外資亂搞事的
我都知道
不然為什麼
昨天可以三個展規盤
三個展規盤
我是跟大
你看很多說有哦
你看
有哦
小韓是莉莉的代班
小韓沒有
以前莉莉之前是小韓
不是莉莉
小韓莉莉在班
應該一一之前也是小韓
小韓應該算一一的代班
OK
哲哲我是每次那個字幕版
留言頭像會員
是喔
第一次可以跟到完整版直播
我愛你們
好不好
我跟你講
你們也不要覺得我在鬥爭
誰不誰
我會鬥爭藍跟綠
拜託
我跟你舊舌認識啊
好不好
我這個規矩要來
台中這裡中午大黑
現在風超越大
烏雲整個蓋起來
風大 但這個風
我絕對不用到要放假
你聽懂嗎
就是規矩什麼
擁有最多展停板的男人
昨天有三個展停板
而且都是有價的量
南亞科
是不是
精彩
環球精
是嗎這樣說
是啦 好不好
群聯股價有機會串情高
當然有機會啊
群聯老闆在買啊
是不是 好不好
像新生 則則越來越看了
你久了就知道
其實真的
一個人好不好人
我跟你講我跟你講
面相學是這樣子
看我看我
不好意思自我介紹
面相學我看起來看很多人
面相學是這樣子
看起來是好人
不一定是好人
看起來是壞人
通常是壞人
我講真的嗎
很多人說我看起來是好人
我是不是好人
沒關係
你久了再多看我的節目嘛
實際行為
所以面相學是滿準的
這樣子
我多年的觀察
面相學是這樣子
看起來是好人
有可能是好人
但不一定
看起來是壞人臉
基本上都是壞人臉
而且那眼神
很邪惡的眼神
那看得出來你知道嗎
這想什麼
邪惡的眼神看得出來
好不好
眼神最重要
還有人就這邊
有人說我天平飽滿
面向滿重要的
今天沒化妝嗎
臉很自然
我有化妝
怎麼可能沒化妝
我們那個
兩個化妝車來
我們公司怎麼沒有
就是重金聘請
什麼沒有
我們就砸錢
砸錢
貨員給我們錢
我們在砸錢在哪邊
砸錢
砸錢在
在研究上面
砸錢在公司員工上面
砸錢在員工旅遊上面
你知道
我們本來要想要去杜拜的
可是後來杜拜我們怕
有一點點戰爭
我們沒有怕啦
每個人這樣有不同
然後後來我們就去布拉格
票更貴
貴很多
是啊 已經其實要十幾萬
十五萬
我們選的旅
我們去個北海都快十萬塊了
這跟大家講
好 車遠的
來
我不要好人 我要去賺錢
沒有錯啊
所以很多人說我很帥
或我是好人也不重要
啊
我會賺錢就帥
我不會賺錢就醜
中美青明天會一起拉嗎
好不好
來
好 紅海是不是
這些問題
來 哲哲今天先休息一下
今天沒有Lily
我比較少喝水
要準備那個簡訊稿
沒關係
我休息一下跟你講其他的股票
剛才都摸摸了
正式開眼
真的新的股票
還有新的盤勢
休息一下 麻煩
馬上有時候大家可以討論我
就念一下
基本上
不要過度的醫美整形
這是老天送給你的
你知道有時候你臉上一顆痣
反而很特別
是跟大家講
好 來
來
蜖蜖一人組成不錯
蜖蜖頭髮有點不自然
什麼自然
你有沒有請小孩摸一下
你知道我頭髮不用吹就這麼翹耶
搞不清楚狀況啦
天生翹
天生翹看那麼軟那麼軟
軟到要命耶我跟你講
我頭髮很軟你知道
來
你看這麼軟還這麼翹
好啦 車遠的
禮拜一開盤為什麼危險
開盤沒有什麼危險
開盤會漲啦
禮拜一開盤會漲
除非今天韓國股市
除非今天國際股市跌
好不好
一...不是一...
金金金金也有上班
金金請一下那個
幫我給我看韓國最新的報價
我們來看一下
來
看一下韓國
剛才看一下
費半有沒有看到
納斯達克
費半昨天漲3%
納斯達克漲1%有沒有看到
經濟的台紫期
是不是
應該
夜盤是漲大概633點
台灣股市剛才漲大概2% 3%
日期本身股市漲
所以基本上
禮拜一台灣股市在漲
可是台灣股市最大的缺點是
都沒有跌
這是優點的缺點
優點就是哇 一枝獨秀
缺點就是
會不會人家漲上去的時候
他也不漲
因為他不跌啊
你聽懂嗎
他沒有辦法
他如果沒有辦法當一個領頭羊
你懂我來說嗎
台灣股市
人家就這
人家假設股市這樣子
在這邊嗎
他們家有很多股市在這邊
在這邊
像很多股市在這邊
你看喔
韓國股市大概在這邊
你這邊反彈
這是韓國股市
假設這邊反彈強烈反彈
你台灣股市很難
除非也不能說很難
以前很難今年不一定
一直獨秀直接穿新高
不是你都沒有跌
你這樣反彈的時候
你也彈一樣的幅度
比較少見
聽得懂嗎
正常的以前正常的就是
哇好不容易他看跌
台灣股市看跌
韓國股市
韓國股市喔
韓國股市反彈了
台灣股市大概只會彈這一點點
等它漲上去的時候
我們再一起追
大概是這樣子
等它創新高的時候
我們再一起創新高
以前會這樣子
今天比較難說
所以我就說台灣股市的優點是很看跌
缺點也是因為看跌
人家跌的時候他沒跌
會不會漲的時候
他也沒跟著漲
可是至少不會跌啦
好不好
不能說至少不會
不能說百分之百
我們是分析師
跟別人一樣呢
關於分析師
好不好
這跟大家講
都預告在前面
好不好
來
這真的
算西裝好好看
你這樣講
維新布局很久
可以開噴嗎
為什麼維新買
你有沒有發現到
其實有時候我比投信還投信
投信現在都會買低基期的股票
你記不記得來
你們看之前都會怎樣
我不是要嗆那個981
姚慈基姆他們很厲害
壓力真的很大
但是承受的壓力我就很佩服啦
說老實話
可是你看搖瓷金母
環球機賣多少錢
你們都知道賣500多塊
看起來環球機要2000塊
少賺300%欸
怎麼辦
我不是嗆他們啊
是不是
他們現在最大的問題是
被人家用放大計看
就那時候以前我超級紅的時候也是一樣啊
我一次抓到6000點的人
我那時候超級紅
辦個演講三四千 三四千人
我覺得我現在辦演講應該有2000人以上
有期待嗎
等我過段時間
哲哲現在還在修身養性中
扯遠的
微星投信在偷學我們嘛
那投信在買啊
低基期啊
你看這邊投信在買很多
有沒有看到
投信一直買有沒有看到
為什麼為什麼
你看喔
微星我講多久啊
他們之前你看最近人一直買
有沒有看到
為什麼
低基期
我跟你講你這個線
這個線 要是我是外資
這個微星的線圖實在太漂亮了
我投信我以嘴
而且我相信喔
一定有外資
一定有外資投信
因為投信一定有人偏偏看著微星
什麼時候拉上去
再講一次喔
因為我太了解投信的手法
一定有投信
而且不少投信的經濟經濟人
派人或自己
什麼時候微星突破152.5元
就這一波的糕點
他突破的時候怎麼樣
來喔
這基礎線突然你要了解
投信的手法
什麼時候突破152元的時候有沒有看到
突破這邊的時候對不對
我在加碼
他們一定有派人去看
所以當他突破152元的時候
我投信還會在買
這就是投信的手法
投信手法就是追高殺低
哼怎麼聽起來賞戶一樣
不一樣他們追高是真的比你敢追高
可能他們追高不會說
比較少見人
不會說國具的一千多塊我還在追
但有時候會啦
大部分是我突破第一根去追
好 OK 嗎
突破第一根的時候
基本上都會有頭心去追
都會有頭心去追
尤其是基幽谷的時候
所以突破152.5%
所以這邊微星
你要進場了
現在微星的線圖喔這些老AI的線圖喔不要說老AI老電子谷的線圖喔微星最漂亮紅海要等一陣子紅海要等一陣子可是這個看起來很醜你拜託拜託你把環圓除去洗好不好
沒有那麼差
紅海也可以買啦
紅海要等於這樣子
我覺得微星不用等了
有沒有 微星不用等了
剛才有人說我帥
我就多講一點點
好不好 盡量稱讚我一下
沒有啦 不需要了
來
微星已經收
我聲音都正常 有聲音
怎麼一直說沒聲音
沒有聲音這邊畫面嗎
這邊
按個連結直接按個Enter
點一下再按次
重新整理有沒有看到
會吧
出去要進來吧
畫面出去要進來
或者按到別的地方
這個觀眾朋友
颱風沒有放到機箱
就是我講的
要放假沒關係
按規矩放假
今天完全沒有任何規矩
規定要放假
你不能說一個颱風準備假
那以後我來個打掃家園家
是不是沒有做吧
我颱風來了以後
颱風來了以後我要走啊
我給你來個七天巡禮好了
颱風走了以後我要打掃啊
不要啦
台股東台積指數讓人家提款
你知道昨天有個新聞
就是好像欠人家錢
欠人家錢以後不是要把他財產給扣押嗎
然後拍賣嗎
然後他什麼沒有就只剩台積電
然後聽到說台積電要把他賣掉
馬上去把他給他錢
國際局說
不要不要不要不要
你不要罵我台積電
我錢給你
我演真的
不要罵我台積電
外面開始買事件先進的
可我跟你講
中美金的
環球金的利多
最大的利多
是中美金
合金等相關
然後我去中美金就直接了
所以為什麼
台聖課我也提到
是不是跟大家講
你看這邊
為什麼
因為你到時候會
這個都缺貨
就是原來現在很多人才發現
這個
記憶體缺貨
然後擴產的時候
等到記憶體擴產的時候
記憶體擴產是不是利空
對不對
來
你們要解釋什麼
什麼東西都是供給跟需求
我教你們
醫生為什麼
為什麼醫生很會賺錢
不是是台灣的醫生很會賺錢
為什麼
因為台灣醫生不像菲律賓的醫生
不像中國的醫生
人口數這麼多啊
所以一切都是供給跟需求
聽懂 我覺得一切都是供給需求
如果台灣的醫生變多了
那就不值錢了
我講是事實 醫生你們不要生氣
好
然後如果醫生一少了
那不好意思
就值錢了
所以我要講說
細菌為什麼值錢
不是細菌
記憶體為什麼值錢跌
因為細菌太少
需求一多
可以感覺它很少
不是細菌 記憶體太少了
記憶體太少
那需求一多
感覺記憶體變少
好 那現在記憶體
我現在記憶體擴產了
是不是記憶體溢空了
因為記憶體變多了
可是還是漲
因為需求更多
好 可是記憶體一多的時候怎麼樣
就需要散油細菌源
散油細菌源
這些空白的散油細菌源
誰生產的
環球晶啊 臺盛科這些
understand
所以等對相對而言變成
記憶體擴產了
那需求變大了
對不對 供給變少了
相對供給變少了
誰需求變大了
對誰的需求變大
對善有的環球金
understand環球金 OK嗎
所以你看
5483中美金
我是我愛美金
我愛美元
你也要噴囉
禮拜也要噴囉
是不是 OK嗎
當然我要講
最噴的是環球金
中美金
如果你不怕高價股的話
那就買環球金吧
好不好
如果你說低價股
我選買一下中美金
那也可以買一下中美金 OK
那這樣子好了
那對5483的
5-83的那個
5347的世界先進
我邏輯要重新改變
因為我一直之前是覺得
是世界先進也很缺
世界先進跟記憶體的做是不一樣
你懂不懂
做不一樣 經驗代工做不一樣
世界先進做的是像成熟製程的
做像聯電一樣 台積電一樣
只是一個先進製程可以成熟製程的
世界先進也需要散遊的細機源
所以我那時候一直覺得
世界先進不該點
因為環球侵害的力多
我以環球機場的展架
是因為世界間進產量很大
需求很大
結果不是
是記憶體那方面的需要的細菌源
他們都需要善有的細菌源
所以這個中美金這個漲
比如說什麼
中美金與環球金的漲或漲價
對世界間進不一定是個利多
我要重新更正
我要重新更正我之前的邏輯
但也不能算個大利空
而且疊生就是一個怎麼樣
疊聲就是一個最好的立桌
來看一下
投信跟外資也開始買了
開始買 買不多啦
好不好 買不多
真正比較明顯的
就是剛才玩友
你看我說玩友很認真
2377的微信
微信 我要再講一次這件事喔
來喔
我真的感 我真的很政變思考
你知道去年我拿開手機一堆
有人要故意打廣告罵我啦
要故意搞個自救會啦
自救會要告我
要告證明我
您證教所出去證明喔
絕對沒有相關的不法
奇怪的進出
全台灣唯一法院證交所證明
絕不跟主力掛鉤的分寄師
不要說起訴
連不起訴都沒有
什麼意思
前傑
你們連告也不能再告了
要提出聲明
說我要再告
也不行
因為人家警察官覺得
這個就是
你在無理取鬧
則則沒有這一回事
你要就這樣分寄師啊
好不好
所以為什麼
因為我有本事啊
你看我預測到投資在想什麼
外資在想什麼
看我節目就看好像講故事一樣
你告訴我啦
我在問你一件事情啦
昨天台灣股市誰有比金財厲害
創新高有價有量
暫停板
只有金財而已
1800檔我選到最強的
賺了80幾%啊
算了
今天我們加班不要一直跟你臭屁
都賺8090%
這實在啦
來來來 市長 算算
市長傳給我 我就臭屁一下
我們也很認真欸 市長現在在香港
是不是 香港幫我連線一下
沒有讓人家出國啦
當然要給的 pay 要多
給的薪水要多
給薪水不多 香港怎麼會幫忙做事情
對不對 是不是
什麼什麼都沒有 就是敢給
好不好
來
世界也缺貨吧 我剛才講的兩個不太一樣
不太一樣
來
買到送小開始布局了嗎
嗯 你是未緣嗎
那折折管達印得起來嗎
看一下管達
因為管達是公布營收
直接公布營收
還沒有印喔
印不起來了啦
好可憐喔
可是管達 我跟你講
管達線型其實比紅海還更漂亮
其實看什麼大戶要再拉一根就可以了
聽懂嗎
等一下喔
看什麼大戶要拉一根
好不好
其實我台風天
台風天基本上我一定會來錄影
我現在是因為我在六日在修成養戲
因為畢竟我錄了這樣
畢竟我當美食當二十年
我基本上我都沒在休息
所以我現在六日稍微給自己
讓其他老師發官發樂也好
我不需要一直搶人家飯碗
可是我雖然比以前減少了工作量
但我也不能沒有工作量
我跟大家講
說禮拜六爆爆爆就停了
看你至少一次
以後會以會員為主啦
非會員的粉絲的不一定會服務你
不好意思
好不好
所以要給姊姊多鼓掌一點點
姊姊你看我太空和機器人嘛
機器人還不知道我的現在
我的智力
我覺得都還在夢想啦
就是我看不到這個預測性
我們先看AI
機器人有機會啦
你看這些丸力紅有沒有
我有跳舞
都跟機器人跳舞有沒有看到
就跟大家講 好不好
你們整個莫頭都出去玩嗎
是喔 可是你們不要擔心
我們是到那個風關那一天
那附近才開始出去玩
基本上不會影響會員權益
OK嗎
來
有多少錢投資多少
是暗示O-in股市嗎
原金融這樣說
不是說你不要借錢的意思啦
要把世界賣掉還給很久驚人
好不好
來
得現比廣告的影片年輕多
身心靈
身心靈的配合
微星月增
應該可以過152
月增喔
我們看一下微星的營收
那個
那個大家給我營收嗎
可以給我三個月
四個月嗎
那個金金
四個月我看就幫我一下
不行就算了沒關係
來
想要請一下樊軒這個
安順啊這些
別說你們不要問我
不是我的股票
問不完的你看
兼職不認識的四千人
同是天涯無聊人相逢何必成相似
今天想要有四千的沒關係
會員直接優先
如果星期一跌那直接跌到四千萬
星期一不會
OK嗎
再整好認真經驗代表會員謝謝你
我跟你講雖然我現在錄影時數變少了
但我絕對是24小時在工作
為什麼24小時在工作
我連睡覺都這個工作
我喜歡紅機川霸人講的話
施政人講的話
睡覺這個工作
你把睡覺當工作
但有時候睡覺辦法工作當然很嚴肅
就是我睡不到
有時候我睡不到六到七個小時
我逼我自己在睡覺
一定要逼自己睡這個覺
那所以說晚上你不能太多應酬
你聽懂嗎
就算應酬不能太晚
好不好
這只寶貝
Henry 你是難得吧 Henry
群聯要等EPS 要等到8月
群聯不錯啦
你都叫我寶貝了
群聯我覺得不錯啦
自己都在噴了
今天晚上注意一下海力士喔
海力士啊 海力士
就跟大家講
哲哲是不是不像看好宅版
不是嘛 你還記得有宅版
我那時候被人家告
宅版我
是幾百塊出掉了 我忘記了
我忘記是五六百 六七百
我忘記了 我忘記了
反正我賺了一百七十趴 一百六十趴
我心情我那時候買在一百塊耶
一百塊左右耶
你現在說一千塊了
我就出掉了 我幹嘛
這要談戀愛是不是
談戀愛有很多人不吃回頭草了
不是 我說他們做幹嘛
你去想你去捐失求
假設我欣欣我萬計我出掉
我出掉600塊
你賺到1200很難耶
可是你看喔
我一個500塊的環球金
我容易漲到1000塊
這漲到2000塊
沒錯吧
然後微星很容易
我選低基金
你知道怎麼我這樣
績效好得要命嗎
你知道為什麼像我會員人數最多嗎
大部分也是我會員人數最多
只是有時候要看行情
市場上為什麼會員人數就是說
股票績效好得要命啊
你去打聽一下啊
我一陣子一直跟你講
所有會員所有股票
所有進出賺錢
我能騙人嗎
這麼多人看著我
你看之前有人無聊到
之前有人無聊到
稿子就會好要告我
幸好從來在投資上面
我從來不騙人的
我敢講那種話
什麼之前所有的股票
所有會員所有進出賺錢
代表我那一陣子
前陣子跡象很好
放到現在還是很強
你看昨天要參個展評板
所以我要講說
那為什麼可以參個展評板
因為我選低級級的股票
我選1400元的
的那個
1400 1500的聯發科
而我不去選擇
快5000元的聯發科
懂嗎
只是在股市渣男
對 我要當股市渣男
平常你不要當渣男
感情上你不要當渣男
股市一定要當渣男
把你最青春年華拿走
丟給別人
好
來
今天直播可以延長啦
反正放過台風價
不要啦 不要延長
我們要不要不要
我們跟他看
直播人數大概一減少就走了
好不好
差不多 幾分了
不行不行
不能講太多
我們還有人幫我打字幕
等一下要打字幕
好不好
南電長大前緣
對那時候我南電新親警
做的在推薦
安順是我的會員
安順
我也是安順是一輛股票
對不起
安順什麼想法
投資股票不是談戀愛
對對對
假日海利是
HDR 狂噴的話
群年下週是不是也要狂噴啊
這兩個連結性沒那麼高啦
沒有那麼高啦
生歷史可能比較有機會
當然我覺得記憶體是整個一起的
好不好
好啦好啦 安順
不是
不好意思 我以為是
我也安順是這場股票好啦 安順你有什麼問題呢世界也算歷史新高啦有喔 營收喔來 營收是不是金金可以給我世界的營收嗎
金金我等你啊
四亞我等你啊
四亞我愛你喔
香港連線好不好
辛苦你了
不過要贏獲得福啊
因為早點可以早點去吧
應該是去香港嘛
應該是
我會員可以作證
金財環球金 藍亞
會員你是藍亞科嗎
藍亞科都暫停
會員作證
金財環球金 藍亞科都暫停了
會員就放大 會員作證有沒有大
放大有沒有大
小孩民就可以放大
我會員可以作證啦
有沒有大
買一T我都軟男好不好
身體六月 六月 六月 六月 六月 六月
我不知道
不好意思 有時候會漏新聞
我們看一下
所以你們趕快問我問題好不好
至少是最新
你們看有沒有漏掉
我漏掉什麼最新的消息或新聞
你來請我解讀
我最喜歡這種感覺
因為我不喜歡被漏掉消息
你看唯新不錯唯金
唯新還有有點比其太來啦
至少算那個
二月以來的新高嘛
178億嘛
算OK
沒有算很好
但算OK啊
因為他連增率負的啊
連增率負的
等到連增率變增的
增的
然後月增率也變增的時候
那個月份應該你才會看到
股價已經上160了
我記得我一件事
當你看到年真率震的時候
月真率震的時候
應該有人會先知道
所以那時候股價已經160以上了
以前我沒記錯200多塊
就是我說的
維新也是什麼
低基期的股票
世界監禁來了給了
我跟世耀那個說
說謝謝他
馬上就船來了
世界監禁公布營收
沒有公布啊
有公布嗎
還沒有公布吧
6月嘛 是不是
有公布的跟我講一下好不好
59.81
OK嗎
沒有關係啦
我們最後還是跟大家講一下
我們那個簡訊好不好
我順便喝個水
你們想要拖
我也不要啦
我停了再五分鐘好不好
我們再五分鐘結束好不好
我們看
可是五分鐘我隨時有報點喔
唸一下
王友晶暫停嘛
沒錯 精彩暫停喔
精彩暫停對不對
我們唸一下精彩好不好
昨天暫停嘛
跳功時說是暫停
來 我們請一下
那個
小韓用一一的聲音
是是是
來
7月9號禮拜四
欸畫面
你為什麼不切換我
這要插臉
算你用你的聲音好不好
趕快把我聲音給去掉
7月9號禮拜四
恭喜3374精彩
股價連兩天噴漲停
突破再創歷史新高
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺83%
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續報
恭喜大家
賺大錢囉
為你簡訊喔
我的績效實在在
透透明明
很透明
很實在
黃耀金
也是一樣
你再幾個展聽板
我點聽板敢買的
所以我這發不成點聽板啊
所以開盤真的比較好
如果開盤有股票跌
我們是不是可以買很多
華爾街730買的股票
也看起來到禮拜一要展一倍了
不然730就要展一倍了
才6月的事情而已
華爾街最高已經獲得145%
我不只買了730
我買了很多次
然後買四五次以上
唉
這跟大家講
有公布了最新的日子
剛才四雅沒給我
後來變最新的日子
哎呀四元星是六月營收
沒錯啦 我頭暈了
六月營收是最新的
對對對 我頭暈了
來喔
六月營收是59.8億
59.8億
欸很好欸
這個營收不錯
這個營收很好喔
這是歷史金剛嗎
欸是耶是耶
2025年到現在
所以你看我們是不是有大
我們是不是裡面有很多大戶很多
不是大戶啦很多認真研究的
喔四元星不錯
喔幸好我最近加碼蠻多
它跌我就買了
我剛剛講的環球金是這樣
所以有時候
你們為什麼有些股票在罵我
我們奇妙不喜歡我這兩件事
脆出有尬詞就跟我對坐
看誰活比較久
你有看到哪個人說因為對坐
你相信我啦
我這麼多一百多萬粉絲
一定有好幾萬人討厭我啦
你有看到哪個人說
因為公共中對坐財富大增的
你們一個都沒聽到啦
一個都沒聽到
不要胡扯了啦
我的盤感跟一般人不一樣啦
扯遠了來
事業先進拉一回就買了
所以本月串新高
看不好 因為有些人今天還是會公佈營收
趕快 現在幾分了
15 來 不行 沒有 我趕快
所以世界先進很漂亮喔 好不好
有 創立新高
受惠經驗出貨增加
那可是我告訴你
最大受惠者會是什麼
則穿在很像行星 有沒有
金特務
沒有啦
來
那個
這什麼都看一下
世界先進
公佈六月合併營收
單月營收喔 創力新高
月增40% 年增33%
然後收衛晶圓的出貨量增加
所以最大利多是什麼
世間金嗎 世間金很漂亮
世間金需要什麼
善油的細晶圓
機體呢 還是需要善油的細晶圓
最大利多是 不好意思
環球晶 中美晶
台股No.1是什麼
呵呵
啊 這是半百半相送啊
我不在乎啦
合金
這些股票
台聖科這些股票
那種不好意思嗎
就這邊
這個晶圓代工這邊
成熟製程這邊
先進製程這邊
需要矽晶圓
他們營收也創新高
機體營收也創新高
都需要散油的什麼
矽晶圓
都需要環球金
天啊
所以在例如說這個好不好
你們看
世界感覺環球金比較有寫
你硬要說是這樣子
只是如果我是積極投資者
我會這樣做
就這樣
就是我也不一定買裝備金
我會環球金
你講的沒錯
你要選最蠢的
OK嗎
看到者的表
者的表是怎麼樣
還可以啦
好
好來
我可以做正則
一直認真工作
之前凌晨四點
居然回訊息
謝謝你啊
整個早說世界看300人
其他分析是沒折折看得著
你這個在稱讚我嘛
等照300人再說好不好
世界有機會300人
有機會300人
300以下紅海也可以買
群聯月增8.9%
最新的是不是
是啊
不好意思再給我一個新的
就剛才那個表
在暗示我們的生命
在暗示我們
看一集少一集
大家要珍惜
我媽媽很討厭的說過這句話
我說實在貨啊
我說實在貨
所以你們要幫我按讚啊
好不好
發願努力賺錢要捐
捐法機以後就會發現
法機是什麼
我是就捐救護車嘛
我也捐了一
公開捐就捐了幾千萬
你都知道都可以查
好不好
折什麼星座
就跟大家講
折價一折價
有時候不需要那麼在乎
有些ADR這些
折的這屆世界杯
哪一隊最有冠軍下
要下注了
很多人還是覺得法國比較厲害
法國三箭頭嘛
我沒有研究喔
這是我很少研究
好欸 直播這差不多時間了
都一樣的
所以不多不少
有些人休息
有些人不齊了
只要怎麼加你會員
很簡單
打電話0806808
我會加我LINE私訊我
上面是藍色的盾牌嘛是不是
藍色盾牌打勾的
就是官方認證
點大頭貼又寫以認證
好不好
以這些為主好不好
日本甚高細經驗暫停喔
是啊
不好意思你們很認真
金金給我那個日本勝高
日本勝高
所以你看日本勝高展
你看我剛才邏輯是不是對
所以禮拜一明天要展
謝謝你
所以當分譯師說
我喜歡你們問我問題給我
我真的忘記
我要去查日本勝高的走勢圖了
他也是做西晶園
那代表就是我講的
禮拜一就是西晶園的股票
中美金環球金和金台勝科要搶了
幹嘛
就別的國家做西晶圓跟黃耀青做一樣的
今天大漲啊
哦來來
日本升高
等一下我看一下哦
哦不只展15%耶
展15%耶
7月4號
我看紀錄線圖
今天展15%馬上給你哦
我看我做事情很快啊
不好意思
會不會覺得無聊
我很怕無聊
來來馬上給
做事情會很快
所以有時候我念助理喔
他們都很怕我念
因為我做事情非常快
來已經給你了馬上
群年新高
不錯我覺得台風價很多
我沒想到你看我要寫世界經濟的營收
微星的營收
群年的營收
對不對
很棒喔
還有那個日本正高
就是矽晶圓的東西有沒有
我覺得今天滿棒的
來看看日本上高
35%
你去買什麼二極體啊
功率半導體啊
備動元件啊
你買這幹嘛
你為什麼買新題材
黃球精你自己看喔
黃球精你覺得很貴
來讓我們冷靜一下
看一下
看一下看一下
6488黃球精用周千來看
以前最高多少
以前最高有差不多
2021年就972
现在1300有很多吗
多个30% 40%有很多吗
这第一个
第二个我们看中美金
中美金以前最多有多少钱
有249元
2022年
那时候中美金
那时候台湾股市是1-2万点
2万点的台湾股市
中美金249元
快5万点的中美金
还是200多元
对吗
还更便宜
低机型
日本升高一天
就是算矽晶圓的
35%
你看你們問什麼
你看很多人就是有在做研究
你們問什麼就直接考我什麼
說我喜歡跟你互動
一般老師不敢開直播互動
開這麼專業的
你們直接問我營收
我就知道答案了
要結束了
好不好
氣氛化學也是長的
所以下禮拜一是矽晶圓
我剛剛有看我邏輯人
對喔
世界先進營收好
記憶體也營收好
他們共同是什麼
散油的矽晶圓
好 四天經紀也不錯喔 好不好
這次最認真 好不好
射手 我是射手
要不要來唱歌
小孩有沒有唱
喔 我是神射手
會不會
Rock and wall
我是神射手
好 不錯了
記得要給我大畫面
看你們跳舞沒看跳到
算了 我不想跳
節奏還好
喔 第一次看我這樣跳
好啦 哲遠了喔
哲遠拜拜 下週一見啦
欸 剛剛才
所以下禮拜一個OK喔
群聯營收也不錯喔 好不好
看一下群年 群年 群年 最後給你群年
不行不行 我要群年了
這要結束了 要結束了
群年 群年 群年
你看對不對
營收249億 不錯
你看每天都增加個20億 很恐怖耶
這個100億到249億
你說群年不會漲
真的很誇張
40007 你根本不覺得我選的選基優股
然後都不是股價很高的股票
你不覺得我對你很好
下禮拜一的重點是那個矽晶圓好不好
環球晶好不好
40007也不錯
群年營收也創新高
微星也不錯
這個我的選股票的技術線
你真的好漂亮
这个股票选择都不错
不论对我有错
我欢迎来电架的钱 080668085
好不好
不论对我有错
泽泽10001000的预划钱购
然后你想买标股的话
欢迎来电架
080668085
或者加我赖私企业
说泽泽
我想插会员
泽泽你好准喔
泽泽你好优风趣喔
泽泽你好帅喔
重点是我要买最妙的标股
让你赚大钱
谢谢各位
拜拜
观众朋友们注意哦
最近诈骗盛行
我泽泽只有三个官方账号
除此以外都不是哦
第一個帳號是LINE的官方帳號
LINE ATT-S178
還有Telegram的官方頻道
小阿索A178-178
還有Telegram私人帳號小阿索A178-178
反正如果是多一個或少一個單字
通通都是假冒的喔
只有這三個帳號
謝謝喔